hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play which the
heart ending I'm gonna go get my heart
on that's so funny
okay anyway um so it shouldn't be too
long of the video so maybe there be a
special surprise at the end probably not
probably not maybe I don't know then I
go to one then I go up here and this is
where I was murder lies before and I go
from 1 to 2 hello baby yeah yeah that's
great hello baby you still creepy his
book ok now there's this Hamar like
crotch again why can't I remember how to
crouch all right click that's weird I
forgot I forgot that you do that really
attached manikin ok someone said behind
the door behind it I can't even get
behind the door oh come on someone said
behind the door we're on the ground
somewhere maybe it wasn't this room
maybe it was another room
oh you didn't jump behind me ok excuse
me ladies BAM can't look up your skirt
okay fine if you're just gonna be a
prude about it umm I swear if someone
said behind that door I thought I
thought they did anyway oh wait no who's
behind the third door okay that means I
gotta get the key out of the the sink
hole and then I gotta stuff it in a lock
hole and then I gotta crank it around a
little bit
oh hello I know you didn't like me
all right whoa oh oh oh no oh no oh no
okay so it was buying a third door that
you guys said it was Tommy go find it
I'm a little too close to the microphone
then I'm gonna go find it and use my
sexy sultry radio voice to entice this
later
hello baby good thing I didn't unlock
that door okay someone say I heart yeah
does a thingy
there's the head key I got both so let
me go get the heart come with me lady ah
you is so fine come here are you right
behind me what right behind me no oh
there you are that's still really creepy
but okay
here we go everybody ooh hello okay I
gotta get out of the way so she can get
it there you go
there you go lady whoo
yes mm-hmm
stuff it in your house weird now your
heart is full oh hello okay you went to
up to the exit
maybe yes no yes no trying to get away
huh
he's not working no is there a way to
get her both her heart and her head or I
don't think that I don't think that
works that way yep you can read that
with your eyeballs and all that yeah oh
no
Oh oh man that's really hard to kill
people in this game apparently goodness
gracious oh my oh damn
that's kind of sad okay and walk into
the light
and that's it that is the heart ending
so since that was so short I will let
you guys in on a little secret oh no oh
no it's all gone
oh no anyway I'll let you guys in a
little secret I got a special coupon
code for my Spreadshirt site there are
15% off t-shirts that's always useful if
you want to buy one you can use that
coupon code or anything else in the
store the code is down in the
description below
it's called best fans ever BES TF ans
Eevee er fr I wanted to spelled mr and
since this video is also super here's
some video of me dancing
[Music]
okay that's all you get right so thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye